bonjour chaunac
on va reparler un peu de votre rapport
de votre commission d' enquête sur le
terrorisme alors vous avez évoqué les
critiques émises par bernard cazeneuve
sur votre travail mais il ya eu aussi
des critiques une plutôt des réserves
émises par des députés de droite comme
guillaume larrivé qui faisait partie de
la commission il a émis des réserves sur
la création d'une agence nationale de
lutte contre le terrorisme
également sur la projection de deux
troupes en irak qui comme comment
expliquer ça il ya un lien il ya une
absence de solidarité au sein de la
commission sur sur l'ensemble des
propositions pour ce qui concerne la
projection des troupes en irak c'est une
idée qui est vraiment très personnelle
aux rapporteurs de laquelle d'ailleurs
je me désolidarise aussi on en a parlé
peu après dans une commission denquête
vous n'êtes pas obligé d'avoir la même
opinion sur tout même quand même si vous
appartenez à la même cour en politique
je suis en désaccord parce que moi j'y
suis allé à washington
j'y suis allé national counterterrorism
center
j'ai pu me rendre compte à quel point
après les attentats du 11 septembre
le renseignement américain s'est
totalement bouleversé transformé par un
vrai partage d'informations je suis
convaincu qu'en la coordination du
renseignement français n'est pas
positionné bon niveau c'est pas au
ministre de l'intérieur a coordonnée qui
n'a pas l'autorité sur mise la défense
qui a lui-même du renseignement il n'a
pas autorité sur ministre du budget qui
a lui-même du renseignement donc il faut
coordonner au plus haut niveau de l'état
c'est un premier ministre ou président
la public et là-dessus effectivement
guillaume larrivé à une autre perception
mais je pense qu'on aura l'occasion d'en
discuter entre les lignes dans les
critiques de guillaume larrivé c'est
qu'en fait le rapporteur socialiste
sébastien pietrasanta a émis ces
propositions que vous étiez amené allait
aller valider ce que ça s'est passé
comme ça on a tellement été convaincu
par ce qu on a vu où nous étions
entièrement d'accord il ya eu des
échanges entre nous pendant tous nos
trajets pendant pendant nos travaux
évidemment échangés en permanence on a
vécu ensemble pendant cinq mois
on est allé dans différents pays et de
ce qu'on en a vu on en est revenu avec
la conviction qu'il faut restructurer
complètement le renseignement français
autre question par loin de la primaire à
droite le évidemment le sujet de la
lutte contre le terrorisme et centrale
quel est selon vous le candidat qui
présente l'arsenal le plus complet sur
cette question là on a un projet celui
des républicains qui a été adoptée au
conseil national
et c'est ce projet là qui est fondateur
et qui doit inspirer et la mort inspiré
par nicolas sarkozy
on sait toute sa sensibilité sur ces
questions de sécurité lequel j'ai changé
j'ai moi même présidé à une table ronde
sur la sécurité les soutenir pour le
dans la course à la primaire s'il est
candidat oui oui de la ville depuis
toujours j'ai toujours soutenu nicolas
sarkozy je continue à le soutenir parce
que je pense je pense que c'est celui
qui a plus d'expérience je pense que
c'est celui qui a encore le plus
d'énergie et de vision et en même temps
tiré aussi les échecs du passé et donc
on a un candidat dont font pas assez sur
le question de sécurité du si je pense
que jean françois copé a une très grande
sensibilité là dessus je pense que
françois fillon aussi ai-je ajoute alain
juppé mais je pense que celui qui a le
plus de conviction d'expérience pour
avoir été lui même ministre de
l'intérieur c'est quand même nicolas
c'est justement vous même georges fenech
vous pourriez porter cette refonte
radicale du renseignement dans un
prochain gouvernement je n'ai absolument
pas cette ambition là sauf si on me l'a
demandé
nicolas sarkozy justement il propose
l'assignation à résidence pour les
fichiers c'est ce que c'est une bonne
mesure selon vous est-ce qu'elles
respectent les droits la présomption
d'innocence
attention à la fiche est ce un
instrument juridique pour contrôler et
surveiller s'il ya des conséquences de
ce type là il ya plus de fiches
est ce parce qu'apparemment on l'inscrit
qui cassent une fiche est-ce donc il
sort des radars mais ce que veut dire
nicolas sarkozy est là je le rejoins
totalement
c'est cette question des gens
extrêmement dangereux notamment ceux qui
reviennent des théâtres extérieurs on
peut pas les laisser dans la nature
comme star il faut des mesures
exceptionnelles
je pense qu'il faut tenir compte de leur
état dangereux et que l'état
s'organisent pour qu'il y ait à titre
préventif des mesures de contrôle voire
coercitives voire assignation à
résidence
voir rétention administrative limité
dans la durée sous le contrôle du juge
je suis persuadé qu'il faut expulsion
pour les jeunes sortent les
ressortissants étrangers double peine
c'est à ça vole soirée ça fait même plus
des barjots on va changer de sujet on va
parler de d'emmanuel macron d'entre eux
va probablement beaucoup parlé la
semaine prochaine puisqu'il va faire un
meeting un grand meeting on annonce
salle de la mutualité à paris
on annonce donc son départ prochain du
gouvernement est ce que vous le
souhaitez ce que vous appelez de vos
voeux le départ d'emmanuel les millions
du gouvernement
oui ça le regarde entièrement j'aime pas
de conseils donnés et je n'ai pas non
plus de voeux à émettre ce serait à mon
avis quand même logique lavier pris
position sur cette question notamment
lors d'un voyage de manuel 1 sur la
longue sur le plan institutionnel oui je
pense qu'il ya une difficulté en quand
on est ministre en exercice de en même
temps alimenté son parti politique
en marge de ces déplacements
ministériels moi ça me pose un problème
déontologique vous aviez saisi la haute
autorité pour la transparence dans la
vie publique
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire où en
est cette saisine j'ai reçu la réponse
cette semaine
alors qui est alors je vous le donne en
primeur qui est ça ne relève pas de
notre compétence ça relève de la
compétence de la commission nationale
des comptes de campagne je ne suis pas
d'accord je vais donc à répondre à
nouveau à la haute autorité pourquoi je
ne suis pas d'accord
on a créé la haute autorité pour la
transparence david public justement pour
éviter ce genre de situation ben moi je
ne dis pas que mes mails macron comme et
des inégalités il a le droit d'avoir un
parti de le financer
question je me pose une question de
nature dit anthologique la haute
autorité ne m'a pas répondu
dès qu'on pose une question difficile on
vous répond pas dans ce pays moi
j'entends ce que la haute autorité me
répond donc je vais relancer à nouveau
la haute autorité parlons un peu des
législatives et des investitures puisque
c'est là la période dans le rhône votre
département une déléguée de sens commun
c'est le mouvement formidable alors anne
l'orne alors exceptionnel elle est jeune
elle est dynamique elle a des idées
elle a des convictions et je suis je
suis très heureux qu'elle soit investie
résolution d'investiture
aussi soutenu par laurent wauquiez c'est
une jeune femme qui est bourré de talent
et qui va certainement décoiffé pendant
cette campagne
dernière question peut-être dimanche
c'est la finale de l'euro de foot au
stade de france
est-ce que vous avez des craintes
concernant la sécurité de ce match
oui j'ai toujours des cra la saint denis
j'ai toujours des craintes tant que la
compétition n'est pas terminée
j'ai toujours des craintes et j'espère
que rien ne se produira pour l'instant
rien ne s'est produit race à dieu mais
il faut être extrêmement vigilant
vous avez des pistes également avec les
renseignements peut-être vous qui
travaillez avec la justice et au monde
d'après la commission vous avez présidé
vous souvenez notamment de ce qu'on a
retrouvés dans les ordinateurs dans les
messages d'un malade quand il disait ça
va être à cimetière c'est cet euro etc
donc il y en a il ya une pensée
effectivement de commettre des attentats
alors je pense que quand même là les
mesures ont bien été prises